[Musik]
tunican herzegovicom
professor hendrix danke, dass du
mich hast
hendrix gut mal sehen jetzt sind sie drin wir sind in der
philosophie stehen sowieso stoned also lass uns
jetzt ein bisschen in der philosophie bleiben
äh donald trump geht ständig hin
und her
mit den fakten und  die Nachrichten also mit den
Nachrichten sind bei ihm,
er wird ihnen vertrauen, und wenn etwas dagegen
spricht, sind es gefälschte Nachrichten,
also die ganze Idee, dass
Sie von Zeit zu Zeit ein Reflexionsprinzip durchsetzen können
, also wenn Sie die Fakten haben,
nehmen Sie sie  Wenn sie gegen dich sind,
sind sie Fake News,
ja, und dann hat natürlich auch der frühere
Pressesprecher des Weißen Hauses,
Sean Spicer, vom
Weißen Haus gesagt, dass
wir, das Route House, den Tatsachen so oft widersprechen werden,
wie kannst du nur  stimme den Tatsachen nicht zu,
ohne falsch zu liegen, also
denke ich, dass Aristoteles zweimal in seinem Grab kriminieren wird,
wenn er jemals so etwas gehört hat
,
zahlt sich das Prinzip der Widerspruchsfreiheit aus,
also wenn Donald Trump
hin und her geht, ob  äh oder nicht,
er hat gesagt, was er gesagt hat, aber in Bezug auf
das Charlottesville-Problem,
ja, das haben wir kürzlich. Zuerst
sagte er,
äh, ich gehe nicht, ich werde nicht mit dem
Finger auf einige zeigen, und dann, ja,
später tue ich es und  dann noch einmal darauf zurückzukommen
und zu behaupten, dass die Nachrichten gefälscht waren
, sie zu melden, weil er gesagt hat,
dass er tatsächlich gegen die weißen
Rassisten und die Nazis
sei, ja, das ist es auf jeden Fall, und man kann mit
Sicherheit sagen, dass Populismus das ist, was
Populismus nicht ist  politische ideologie ein populismus
ist eine strategie
eine strategie für die man
entweder linken oder rechten populismus haben
könnte also könnte man sagen le pen
ist rechter populismus trump ist rechter
populismus ist
ist äh sein rechter populismus aber
andererseits war hugo chavez linker populismus also ist
es so  nicht so sehr eine Ideologie, sondern
eine Strategie, mit der
Sie eine bestimmte, sehr klare
Person oder Gruppe gegen sich geltend machen, also stehen sie
gegen uns,
ob wir als Brüssel, Washington, der
Rostgürtel,
die Fetten, die Armen, die Ri  ch und so
weiter und so weit
und und der Grund,
warum das sehr gut funktioniert, ist, dass
es nur einen Grund für mein Problem gibt,
und Sie können auf sie als das Problem hinweisen,
und dann haben Sie eine sehr klare Erzählung, die
sich auf uns versus bezieht  sie und das ist es,
was Populismus wirklich ausmacht
Fake News
Design Fake News
bald Nun, ich meine, ich bin wahrscheinlich in dem Lager, in
dem wir Fake News sind nichts Neues und
es gibt sie
wahrscheinlich so lange, wie wir Menschen sind,
sie gibt es sicherlich
Seit wir Papiere haben
und seit wir Verdünner haben, besteht das
Problem mit gefälschten
Nachrichten nicht darin, dass sie aufgrund der Art und Weise
, wie sie jetzt zusammengestellt werden, neu sind,
also sind gefälschte Nachrichten normalerweise nicht nur falsche
Informationen,
sondern wahr und falsch gemischt
als Compound
und dann so in Umlauf gebracht
, dass es meistens
die Base trifft, für die man schlagen will,
entweder dafür oder dagegen,
und andererseits ist
es meistens so laut und macht so
viel Krach  und
es ist so spektakulär, dass selbst die
Mainstream-Medien nicht widerstehen können,
es aufzugreifen
und ebenfalls in Umlauf zu bringen, und
warum auch, denn
das wichtigste Gut im Internet, das wichtigste
Gut im
Informationszeitalter, ist Aufmerksamkeit, das ist
das wichtigste Gut
und die Art und Weise, wie  Sie
weisen tatsächlich die Aufmerksamkeit der Menschen zu,
und Herbert Simon,
Nobelpreisträger von 1971,
sagte, wenn Sie viele
Informationen haben, haben Sie einen Mangel an
etwas anderem, und wo haben Sie einen
Mangel
an Aufmerksamkeit, es gibt nur 24 Stunden am
Tag,
also haben Sie ein Exponential
Auf der einen Seite steigen die Informationen,
aber Sie sind immer noch auf eine
bestimmte Menge an Aufmerksamkeit beschränkt, die Sie
zuweisen können,
und Sie weisen das durch Informationen zu,
welche Art von Informationen die Leute
wollen, dass wir sie konsumieren,
und gefälschte Nachrichten haben das sehr glückliche,
äh, irgendwie  Dynamik, die es wirklich
erzwingt
, sehr sehr laut und sehr laut zu sein und
dann in Umlauf gebracht und
weit gelesen zu werden,
damit das Informationszeitalter eine Information
hat  Tatsächlich verstärkte Fake-News-Phänomene,
die es schon gibt, seit
wir Menschen sind.
Okay, da ich eine Mission übersprungen habe
, sprechen wir heute mehr darüber,
weil
es anscheinend tatsächlich so aussieht, als würde es
weltweit über soziale Medien prophylaktisch wirken  und andere
Outfits und Outlets
, um diese Zirkusse tatsächlich
in Umlauf zu bringen und diese Geschichten in Umlauf zu bringen,
und aus dieser Perspektive
hat es plötzlich eine Reichweite
und eine Geschwindigkeit, die wir noch nie
zuvor gesehen haben, und seine Reichweite und Geschwindigkeit
machen hier den Unterschied
Warum es heutzutage so viel diskutiert wird
und auch erkennen, dass Geld darin
steckt, wissen Sie, ich meine, insofern als zu sagen, dass
Studien zu den US-Wahlen durchgeführt wurden
, kamen viele der gefälschten Geschichten, die dort
herauskamen, aus Mazedonien und einige
junge Herren produzierten tatsächlich
diese gefälschten Nachrichten und mir wurde klar, dass
sie 347 Dollar im Monat verdienten.
Sie starteten zwei gefälschte Nachrichtengrößen
und erhöhten ihr Einkommen auf
16.000 pro Monat  nth und warum gut im Grunde,
weil
sie an die Werbetreibenden
verkaufen, die sie verkaufen, die sie die Aufmerksamkeit der Hörer verkaufen
Sie
sind wirklich eine
Art Kunde, dann denken
Sie noch einmal, Sie sind nicht der Kunde, da Sie nicht
dafür bezahlen.
Diejenigen, die dafür bezahlen, sind die
Kunden. Betrachten Sie es also im Grunde aus
dieser Perspektive
der sozialen Medien und der sozialen
Medien  Outlets richtig, was sie wirklich
tun,
ist, dass sie die
Aufmerksamkeit der Leute durch Informationen zuweisen
und dann die
Informationen, die sie verkaufen
,
an die Werbetreibenden verkaufen, damit jeder Online-Benutzer
kein Kunde ist, sondern die Produkte,
ausländische,
gefälschte Nachrichten  Okay, wir haben gerade ein
Buch namens Fake News geschrieben und in diesem Buch
graduieren oder granulieren wir verschiedene,
äh, was soll ich sagen, Aussagen darüber,
ob sie sich als qualifizieren oder nicht
Behauptungen, gefälschte Nachrichten,
also in der oberen Balkenzone sind die
verifizierten Tatsachen, die
von deklarativen Sätzen verwendet werden könnten, um Recht zu behaupten.
Ja,
das ist unfair, da ist ein Glas Wasser,
Sie tragen eine Brille usw.
Jetzt sind dies verifizierte Tatsachen und direkt
unter denen
Sie  könnte gerahmte Tatsachen haben oder wenn Sie
manipulierte Aussagen wünschen, sie sind nicht
unbedingt nur unwahr,
sie könnten gerahmt sein, also was wollen Sie,
wollen Sie 90
Beschäftigung oder 10 Arbeitslosigkeit, was
am Ende als die gleiche Angebotsauswahl herauskommt,
wie Sie sich präsentieren  Dinge, man
kann die Fakten herauspicken
und man kann auch bestimmte Fakten weglassen
und nur diejenigen nehmen, die dafür sind
und so weiter, und dann haben sie die Gerüchte am dritten und so könnten die Gerüchte wahr oder
falsch sein,
und dann haben Sie Entschuldigung  Freund Harry
Frank für seinen Bullshit,
der im Grunde absichtlich so gemacht ist,
dass er eine
Art Physik ist, bei der Wahr und Falsch außer Acht gelassen werden,
dann haben Sie
Lügen, die im Grunde falsch sind, und
dann haben Sie gefälschte Nachrichten als Grund  Teilweise sind
gefälschte Nachrichten normalerweise ein gemischtes
Produkt,
aber sie werden präsentiert, um eine echte Nachrichtengeschichte zu simulieren,
und das macht
sie sehr
giftig, weil sie nicht
unbedingt nur
falsch sind, sondern sich ähneln, sie sind im
Grunde eine simulierte Realität
oder eine alternative Realität  Wenn Sie dies wünschen oder
behaupten,
und das macht es viel schwieriger, sie zu
entlarven, da die üblichen Kriterien für die
Entlarvung von
Behauptungen sehr unterschiedlich sind, und selbst
wenn Sie von der philosophischen
Seite kommen
, die wirklich giftig ist
, können wir definitiv sagen, dass es Syrien ist,
aber wir  Ich verstehe nicht wirklich, was die
Quelle dieses Rauchs ist
[Musik],
aber ich denke, der Punkt ist wirklich zu sagen,
dass wir die üblichen Kriterien überschreiten,
nach denen
wir Aussagen bewerten, ja, also wenn es
um
wissenschaftliche Aussagen geht, sind sie es auch nicht
als wahr oder falsch angesehen werden, je nachdem,
ob Sie eine
Methodik finden können, die sie
entweder als wahr oder falsch ansieht,
aber hier transzendieren wir sie irgendwie,
weil f  Eine Neuigkeit
ist, normalerweise auch andere
Erfolgskriterien zu haben, und das sind diese
Erfolgskriterien, um Menschen
von etwas zu überzeugen,
entweder ein politischer Standpunkt, ein moralisches
Ansehen, eine religiöse,
religiöse Neigung, wähle deinen Favoriten aus
, also bist du nicht du  du
kombinierst,
ähm, du nimmst irgendwie den
naturalistischen Irrtum und machst keinen
Irrtum, du nimmst im Grunde,
du kannst sagen,
das ist so und so, aber es muss
so und so sein, und dann werde ich es behandeln
So und so zu sein
und das ist im Grunde das, was Sie mit
gefälschten Nachrichten haben, dass Sie
die Kluft überschreiten, in der wir normalerweise
innerhalb der Philosophie
zumindest viel tun würden, würden Sie, ähm,
gesunder Menschenverstand oh
oder im gesunden Menschenverstand nämlich, dass da
etwas ist  wie die
Dinge sind und dann anders wie die Dinge
sein sollten und Fake News
können tatsächlich die Grenze zwischen Ist
und Kunst
verwischen
Die Skepsis von
Kanadas Nakila übernimmt sozusagen die Plato-
Akademie, nämlich
dass das, was man mit Film machen kann
und was wir mit Filmmaterial usw. tun können, im Grunde
dazu neigt, zu einem Problem der
Unterbestimmtheitsthese zu führen, was im
Grunde bedeutet,
dass es keine klare Grenze gibt  zwischen dem,
was ist, und dem, was nicht ist, oder
der Art und Weise, wie man erkennen kann,
ob wir Gehirn und ein Bottich sind oder nicht,
was ist
, das ist der springende Punkt,
denn wenn man sich dieses spezielle
Filmmaterial ansieht, ist
es sehr schwer zu sagen, ob oder
ob es nicht wahr ist oder ob es ein tatsächliches Ereignis widerspiegelt oder nicht,
es stellt sich heraus, dass es richtig simuliert wurde, so dass
die üblichen Bedingungen, nach denen wir
mit unseren primären Sinnen beurteilen, was ist
und was
nicht, durch die Art und
Weise in Frage gestellt wurden  Sie können
Fingermanipulationen mit
Bildern, Filmmaterial usw. erstellen, sodass Sie aus dieser
Perspektive sagen können,
dass die alte Skepsis
bei seiner ehrlichen Rückkehr in gefälschten Nachrichten auf seiner Seite liegt,
und das ist so
ziemlich t  Der Punkt dieser Mr.
Philosophie
Ja, das ist eine sehr, sehr gute Frage, also
schau, wenn du dich um seine Fingerknöchel
kümmerst, nimmst du das Auto
, nimmst du Humes oder versteckte Quellen der
Natur, nimmst du Putnam,
Gehirne und Fässer, Philosophie,
alle Philosophen, die sich mit Skepsis auf die
eine oder andere Weise befassen  andere, aber sie basieren
auf der sogenannten globalen
Unterbestimmtheit, was im Grunde bedeutet,
dass Sie, egal welche Sinneswahrnehmungen Sie bekommen
, nicht unterscheiden können
,
ob sie simuliert werden oder ob sie real sind, das ist der
springende Punkt, und die Struktur
, die im Grunde auf der gleichen Art von Struktur basiert, die Sie
jetzt erkennen  das auto natürlich das
auto war ein wissenschaftler auch recht er war
er war er machte optik und so
interessierte ihn nicht metaphysische
skeptik ob
die welt ist oder nicht er interessierte sich dafür
ob man den mythen methodologisch annehmen könnte oder nicht
alles und doch eine klare Grundlage
für unsere Erkenntnis finden und er kam am
Ende mit
use your use your mind
yes  Das ist zum Teil immer noch ein Weg, den wir
gehen können, aber der Weg, auf dem
wir das jetzt umgehen, ist, dass wir uns als
Journalisten auch auf die Arbeit
berufen auf eine Reihe von Methoden berufen, um festzustellen,
ob
wir tatsächlich wahrhaben, so sagen wir
es  auf diese Weise, was tun,
was Journalisten gut machen, sie überprüfen
die Quellen mehr als eine,
sie triangulieren die Informationen,
triangulierte
Perspektive, erhalten unterschiedliche Perspektiven,
Bestätigung oder Widerlegung oder
Verfälschung
und wir verifizieren et
cetera, also sage ich mal so
, es gibt jetzt viel mehr
Druck
auf den Journalismus, herauszufinden
und herauszufinden, ob die Art
von Informationen, die uns präsentiert
werden, wahrheitsgemäße Informationen sind oder nicht, aber gleichzeitig besteht die
Herausforderung darin  Die
Menge an Informationen
ist so groß und die Geschwindigkeit so schnell,
dass es eigentlich schwierig ist, dies im
Grunde genommen die
Grundlagen
des Journalismus in Frage zu stellen  Philosophisch interessant
ist, dass, wenn Sie sich die
Forschungsethik der Pew Institutes für gute journalistische
Prinzipien und herausragende Leistungen im Journalismus ansehen,
sie ein Konzept namens journalistische
Wahrheit haben, das bedeutet,
den Fakten zu folgen, soweit Sie
die Informationen triangulieren können,
überprüfen Sie die Quellen und so weiter, und wenn Sie
lesen  Durch diese
10 Prinzipien, auf die sich herausragender
Journalismus beläuft, kommen
sie dem sehr nahe, was Sie
in der Wissenschaftsphilosophie 101 finden würden.
Ja, ich denke, Sie haben sehr recht,
und das Problem ist
in gewissem Sinne ein Problem in der
Information  Zeit, die
Wissenschaftlern und Philosophen ein wenig fremd
ist, ist, dass Informationen jetzt ihren Preis haben,
genau da ist ein Preisschild dran,
manche Informationen sind billig, manche
Informationen sind extrem teuer,
jetzt sind die Informationen, die Sie aus der
Wissenschaft erhalten, normalerweise extrem teuer,
weil
Sie '  Sie müssen überprüfen Sie
müssen Ihre Methodik anwenden Sie müssen
Ihre Quellen überprüfen Sie müssen
epist sein  emologisch
versiert et cetera et cetera wobei
das im Journalismus eigentlich genauso ist,
also gute journalistische Produkte oder gute
Wissenschaftsberichte sind vergleichsweise
sehr teuer, sozusagen
Fake News, die man eben produziert und
in Umlauf bringt und
obendrein meist die Wahrheit  ist nicht so laut,
die Wahrheit ist, was die Wahrheit ist,
also tut es nicht, was auch immer wahr ist, es ist nicht
unbedingt
viral, und wenn es viral ist, ist es nicht
unbedingt wahr,
und da ist Ihr Paradoxon, denn wenn die
Realität ein Maß für die Zuweisung von Aufmerksamkeit ist,
dann eine Zuweisung von Aufmerksamkeit  ist eine Frage
des Geldes
und dann kommen plötzlich Informationen
zu einem Preis, bei dem es
für Sie opportun sein kann, Informationen in
Umlauf zu bringen,
die nicht geprüft werden, aber viel Aufmerksamkeit zuweisen,
während die Wahrheit länger braucht,
um sie zu produzieren  Vielleicht nicht einmal so
gut. Ich denke, zuallererst denke ich, dass es
wichtig ist, mindestens drei
verschiedene Gründe für die Produktion gefälschter
Nachrichten zu isolieren  Ich schreibe auch Fake News in das Buch
, die aus Spaß an der Sache sein könnten,
also bedeutet
das, die Diskussion richtig zu entgleisen, was auch immer es sein
könnte, das könnte tatsächlich für politische
Einflussnahme sein, und es könnte einen monetären
Anreiz geben, also sind das jetzt natürlich die drei Gründe
Sie könnten gemischt
werden,
ähm, aber ich denke, es ist fair zu sagen, dass die
Art von gefälschten Nachrichten, die
wir bisher beeinflusst haben,
und sie können in vielen verschiedenen
Größen und Formen auftreten
, in der politischen Szene
, das ist schon schlimm genug
2013, 14, 15, 16
und 17,
haben das Weltwirtschaftsforum gesagt,
dass Fehlinformationen im Internet jetzt
als globale Herausforderung angesehen werden müssen, die mit der
globalen Gesundheit, der langfristigen Investition, der
Migration
, dem Klima usw. vergleichbar ist
Warum müssen
wir Fehlinformationen als globale
Herausforderung betrachten, denn
wie sie sagen, ist es eine Herausforderung für die globale
Governance, das heißt für Demokratien, wie
wir sie
in der westlichen Hemisphäre und anderen kennen  Überall
auf der Welt und sozusagen aus
dieser Perspektive kann man sagen,
dass diese Fake News von vielen
verschiedenen Orten kommen
und es viele verschiedene Anreize geben mag,
aber sie sind auf lange Sicht giftig und
giftig für Demokratien
,
weil in  Langfristig können Sie
mit einer sogenannten postfaktischen
Demokratie enden,
und eine postfraktale Demokratie oder eine
Demokratie in einem postfaktischen
Zustand ist eine Demokratie, in der
opportunistische Narrative
auf der Grundlage falscher Informationen
zur Grundlage
für Gesetzesdebatten werden
Auch politische Interaktion und
das ist eine gefährliche Situation,
unsere Fiktion und
ja, ich denke, das ist eine sehr, sehr
gute Frage, und dann nehmen wir in den gefälschten Nachrichten
die postfaktische
Demokratie an einem Ende der Skala
und am anderen Ende der Skala  Sie
haben
eine Technokratie, in der alles
nur auf Fakten basiert.
Wir behaupten nicht, dass es einmal ein
goldenes Zeitalter gab, in dem
Journalisten, Bürger und Wissenschaftler lebten
und
die politiker haben die wahrheit und nichts als
die wahrheit gesagt, dass es nie so war, dass es wahrscheinlich
nie so war,
also sieh dir diese beiden im grunde als grenzpunkte
auf einer skala an, wo du je nach zeitgeist
je
nach finanzieller situation in der gesellschaft
hin und her rutschst  in dieser
Größenordnung
und gerade gleiten wir auf
etwas zu, das ein bisschen wie ein
postfaktischer Zustand aussieht
, der aber auch durch
Wissenschaftsjournalismus usw. zurückgegeben werden könnte, also besteht eine Demokratie
natürlich zu
einem Teil aus Fakten und zu einem Teil aus Ideologie oder
Vision oder was auch immer  Sie wollen es nennen,
und diese beiden Verbindungen, die
zusammengemischt werden, ergeben eine funktionierende Demokratie, aber was
wir darüber wissen
und was uns bekannt ist,
ist, dass unsere
Prinzipien
der, sagen wir, Demokratie seit dem Zeitalter der Aufklärung aus dem La
stammen  Auf dieser Grundlage
machen uns Informationen klüger in
Bezug auf die
Entscheidungsfindung, und im Zeitalter der
Informationen ist dies
leider nicht unbedingt der Fall,
wenn Sie  Wenn
Sie den Leuten mehr Informationen geben, treffen sie bessere
Entscheidungen, und
Kant Rizzo und der Rest der
Aufklärer hätten es wirklich schwer
damit, weil sie sich möglicherweise
in das dunkle Mittelalter zurückgeträumt haben, aus dem sie
tatsächlich versuchten, durch
Beschwörung herauszukommen  wissen und informationen
gut schau ich habe einen 17 jährigen sohn okay
jetzt hätte ich einfach für den rest meiner tage mit meinen
konvergenztheoremen
in dynamischer erkenntnislogik und formaler
lerntheorie weitermachen können
aber mein sohn kam vor einigen jahren zu mir
als ich die
bekam  den dänischen Elite-Forschungspreis und
er stellte mir die folgende Frage,
zwei Fragen, eigentlich sagte er, Pop, ich
muss eines wissen,
was Sie tun, das ist eine gute
Frage, aber die zweite Frage ist noch
besser
und warum ist es wichtig und warum ist es so?
wichtig
gut, viel besser als ich es
früher konnte, weil ich
denn im grunde
möchte ich der nächsten generation
eine welt übergeben, die im arsch ist  Bessere Form als
die, die ich von meinen Eltern
bekam und die sich Fortschritt nennt, und im Moment
denke ich, dass das ein bisschen schwer zu erkennen ist,
also versuche ich, die
Methoden der Wissenschaft anzuwenden,
etwa basierend auf der Idee, dass wir
das Geld bekommen haben  von der carlsberg stiftung
, um das zentrum für informations- und
blasenstudien zu starten, und der vorsitzende der carlsberg stiftung, fleming bisonbacker, sagte, als
wir die finanzierung erhielten, sagte er
der website, dass das zentrum für
informationszentrum für informationen
blasenstudien ein zentrales beispiel
für wissenschaftliche gesellschaftliche verantwortung sei  Nun,
SSR, Sie haben also soziale
Verantwortung von Unternehmen. Sie könnten auch
von wissenschaftlicher sozialer Verantwortung sprechen,
und die Grundidee ist, dass wir die Wissenschaft nutzen
, um uns den globalen Herausforderungen zu stellen, vor denen
diese Welt steht,
damit dieser Ort ein besserer Ort wird, auch
basierend auf der
Wissenschaft  Um nicht zu sagen, dass wir das nie getan hätten, aber
dass diese
Agenda jetzt viel weiter verbreitet ist, angesichts der Tatsache, dass sie
jetzt viel präsenter ist
Die Wahrheit wird ein wenig in
Frage gestellt,
aber
oh, ich sollte nicht
extrapolieren, was jeder Philosoph
denken
oder tun sollte. Ich sage nur, dass natürlich
Philosophie für mich im
Grunde Logiker ist, also hier ist eine
Werkzeugkiste voller Logik,
okay jetzt  Bei der Logik geht es im Grunde um
Prinzipien der Informationsverarbeitung,
manchmal gut und manchmal schlecht, und
was sind die Struktur
und die Dynamik der Art und Weise, wie wir
Informationen verarbeiten, das ist
in gewissem Sinne das, worum es bei Logik geht.
Nehmen wir diese Werkzeuge und schauen wir uns das
wirkliche Leben an  Phänomene von
gefälschten Nachrichten auf der einen Seite
bis hin zu Informationskaskaden- und
Zuschauereffekten und auf der anderen Seite,
um herauszufinden, was die
Grundlagen dieser Probleme aus einer
informationsbasierten Perspektive sind,
und um dann zu sehen, ob es vorbeugende Maßnahmen gibt,
die wir dagegen ergreifen können,
sobald wir sie haben  Die mathematischen
mathematischen Modelle im Spiel
, das ist eine Therapie,
und ich kann nicht dahinterkommen, ja, in
gewissem Sinne, ja, und lassen Sie mich Ihnen ein
endlich
interessantes Beispiel dafür geben  dass es jetzt so
etwas wie pluralistische Ignoranz gibt
, das ist ein Betrug, das ist ein
Phänomen, das Sie in der
Sozialpsychologie finden,
und es ist im Grunde die Idee, dass Sie
etwas nicht glauben, aber Sie
glauben fälschlicherweise, dass Ihre Kollegen
das Gegenteil von dem glauben, was Sie glauben
und was Sie  herauskommen kann, ist, dass
man sich kollektiv Normen unterschreibt, die
man privat ablehnt,
also ist es jetzt eine Art Mehrheitsfehler
, die
in allem gefunden wurden, von Risikoverhalten bei
Kindern und Jugendlichen
bis hin zu Trinkgewohnheiten oder Partygewohnheiten,
aber es geht auch  und wir haben gerade eine große
Studie darüber durchgeführt, wenn es um
Cybermobbing geht,
also haben wir 1500 junge Menschen im Alter von 15
Jahren nach ihrer eigenen Einstellung zu Cybermobbing
gefragt
und was sie dachten, was ihre Altersgenossen
dachten, und hier kommt es, dass
sie es selbst nicht mochten  Die
Mehrheit fand
Cybermobbing nicht akzeptabel, aber sie
glaubte fälschlicherweise,
dass ihre Klassenkameraden und insbesondere
ihre Freunde muc waren  h positiver
eingestellt als sie es
selbst waren,
das ist seit einiger Zeit bekannt, wenn
es um andere Risikoverhalten wie
Alkohol usw. geht,
aber jetzt ist es auch bewiesen,
dass es bei Cyber-Mobbing der Fall ist.
Jetzt ist die Frage, was zu tun ist  gut dagegen tun
Eine Sache, die Sie tun könnten, ist,
dass Sie Ihren paternalistischen Finger nehmen und sagen, dass
Sie am Wochenende nicht trinken können oder dass Sie
nicht Cybermobbing können, aber wer das
nicht tut, tut das nicht, das funktioniert aber nicht
Es gab Studien in den USA
, die gezeigt haben, dass,
wenn Sie ein Experiment durchführen, bei dem
Sie einer Gruppe den
paternalistischen Finger geben, tun Sie es nicht,
der rote, die zweite Gruppe, die Kontrollgruppe
, nichts tun und die dritte Gruppe
Sie werden ihnen das A und O
der pluralistischen Ignoranz erklären, und dann, dass an
und für sich zu
verstehen, worum es bei dem Phänomen geht,
tatsächlich eine vorbeugende
Maßnahme für sie sein kann, es noch einmal zu tun
, was Ihnen ein sehr gutes Argument
dafür liefert, warum Sie nachlassen  t diese Dinge zu studieren,
weil
die bloße Idee, die Grundlagen
dieser Probleme
zu verstehen, tatsächlich präventiv sein kann, das gleiche gilt
für gefälschte Nachrichten und andere Dinge,
es ist
[Musik], dass
das Institut
Blasen gut filtert, so
Eli Perez, der sich ausgedacht hat  Das Konzept ist im
Grunde das, was Sie hier gerade gezeigt haben.
Filterblasen sind eines von vielen
verschiedenen Arten von Blasenphänomenen, die
wir am Zentrum für Informationen
in Blasenstudien untersuchen,
aber im Grunde stammen unsere Ideen aus der
Ökonomie, nämlich dass
man Vermögenswerte überhitzen kann und wenn Vermögenswerte
gehandelt werden  Bei Preisen, die ihre
fundamentalen Fundamentalwerte
systemisch weit übersteigen, spricht man in der Regel von einem Bubble
Blaster
Immobilienblasen Aktien
Finanzprodukte wie Derivate
Sie nennen es jetzt Betrachten Sie es aus dieser
Perspektive.
Möglicherweise gibt es andere Arten von Vermögenswerten, die
Sie überhitzen können
keinen monetären Wertstatus haben
Einflusskraft ähm
sogar man kann sogar von Wissenschaftsblasen sprechen
wo bestimmte f  Felder haben
eine Menge
finanzieller oder viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, und
viele andere
schikanieren nicht einmal Blasen, in denen die
Leute nichts getan haben,
aber die Wahrnehmung sagt online, dass
sie etwas getan haben und dann
Sie werden im Grunde
damit oder mit Nachrichtenblasen laufen, in denen
kleinere Nachrichten, Oliver, sicherlich
viel Aufmerksamkeit erhalten,
zum Beispiel gab es eine gefälschte Nachrichtengeschichte,
dass Angela Merkel im Grunde
das ZDF direkt
im deutschen Rundfunk leitete,
was falsch war, aber viel davon bekam  Aufmerksamkeit
und damit Sie überhitzen können, können Sie
andere Vermögenswerte und monetäre Vermögenswerte überhitzen,
und das Interessante daran ist,
dass der Markt zum Beispiel online
sehr liquide ist, da
es viele Handelspunkte
gibt, Upvotes mögen, gemeinsame
Selfies
und es gibt viele verschiedene  uh
liquid bedeutet da draußen,
das bekannteste ist, dass ein
Like
und das Like eine Möglichkeit ist, Ihr Like zu investieren,
ein Facebook-Like, entschuldigen Sie,
und das ist eine Möglichkeit zu investieren  Ihre Meinung,
aber wenn Sie Ihre Meinung investieren können und
ich nicht so aufgeklärt bin wie Sie, aber ich
mag wilde Firmen und ich denke, er
könnte einfach Recht haben, anstatt
mich selbst zu überprüfen,
werde ich mögen, was Sie mögen, weil
wir es sind  auf Augenhöhe oder wir müssen den
gleichen Standpunkt teilen wie Sie
und dann haben wir plötzlich die
Situation, dass alle nach links gehen
, obwohl die richtige Idee ist, nach rechts zu gehen,
und dann können Sie die
Polarisierung der Echokammern verstärken, ähm
und Sie  Wir haben auch kognitive Dissonanzen,
also tendieren wir dazu,
wenn wir Informationen finden, die
nicht mit uns übereinstimmen, tendieren wir dazu, sie zu ignorieren.
Sie haben Informationen, die
wir noch nicht kennen
Laut einer
Studie aus dem Jahr 2009
war
der Online-Traffic der politischen Diskussion zugeteilt. 10 aller Online-Traffics beziehen sich auf Pornos
, das ist also bei weitem
die größte Quelle für Online-
Informationen.
Natürlich sind gefälschte Nachrichten
im Grunde nichts  ossoming jetzt ähm und
oder hat im Ausland
absolut geblüht und es ist ein großes
Thema und warum,
weil es, wie das Weltwirtschaftsforum
sagte,
jetzt als globale
Herausforderung angesehen werden kann, jetzt ist
das Web sehr anpassungsfähig und es ist auch
organisch
und das heißt  dass es ein bisschen schwierig ist
, vorherzusagen,
welchen Einfluss es haben könnte
oder ob
es nur ein vorübergehendes Phänomen ist oder nicht, aber ich
denke, es ist fair zu sagen, dass die
Wahrheit bisher ein guter, ziemlich guter
Begleiter für uns war, was wir nicht wären
sitzen und diese Diskussion führen,
wenn es nicht so wäre, weil es etwas gibt, das
als wahr oder falsch bezeichnet wird, könnten
Sie die Kameras, die wir verwenden, nicht so machen, wie wir
es
tun. Wenn sie also auf gefälschten Nachrichten basieren,
würden sie wahrscheinlich nicht so funktionieren
Die Wahrheit hat uns bisher tatsächlich geholfen
und es wird wahrscheinlich so weitergehen
, aber
schau, es ist nur das, was Facebook von
2004 ist,
okay, also jetzt sind wir in 17. Das sind
jetzt 13 Jahre Erfahrung, die
wir mit dieser Art von Plattform mit 2 haben
Milliarden
Produkte haben wir eine sehr, sehr begrenzte
und wie äußerst begrenzte Erfahrung
mit dem Informationszeitalter, wir sind alle
Teil dieses sozialtechnischen
Experiments, und obendrein Sie und ich,
wenn wir hier an diesem Tisch sitzen, die
Hälfte von dem, was wir sagen, ist nicht was
kommt aus meinem Mund oder aus
deinem lese ich dich und du liest mich
du bist nicht
gut du kaufst diese Prämisse ich fahre
von hier fort ich mag dich und du fährst fort
nur zu sagen das wir uns hier etablieren
indem wir uns in die Augen schauen
Wir legen fest, was wir
als Allgemeinwissen betrachten und was nicht,
und so funktioniert der Dialog,
dass wir uns
sozusagen gegenseitig abkoppeln oder uns kontinuierlich anpassen, wie
wir uns gegenseitig vor
Jahren lesen  Plattform, um diese Art von Dialog zu simulieren,
wo wir so reden müssen,
jetzt kann ich dich
nicht mehr sehen, also können die Zuschauer es auch nicht, oder
die Zuschauer können mich nicht sehen,
nur um zu sagen, ob ich ehrlich
bin, was ich sage
und wie  bald a  Ich mag das, ah, sehen Sie,
es gibt also eine Menge
, die sich die ganze Zeit gegenseitig abliest, und
diese Bedingungen haben es online schwer
, was bedeutet,
dass die Möglichkeit von Fehlern einfach
größer ist,
als es
gut ist, das ist definitiv eine Tatsache, dass, wenn
wir  Informieren Sie sich nicht, Sie könnten
in sehr, sehr großen Schwierigkeiten sein.
Eine Sache, die Sie aus vielen
Informationen gewinnen, sind auch viele neue
Erkenntnisse.
Jetzt ist die Frage, wie Sie sie richtig erfassen,
und das ist im Grunde eine
der Herausforderungen, die wir tun  haben,
also wird viel
über Informationsverarbeitung geforscht und
vieles davon ist sehr wertvoll,
also lassen Sie uns sehen, ob
das die Möglichkeit hat, tatsächlich
ein Gleichgewicht zu finden, in dem die guten
Informationen
überleben
denn das ist im Moment nicht der Fall.
Eines der interessanten Dinge
, die wir uns im Zentrum
für Information und öffentliche Studien angesehen haben, ist,
dass, wenn Sie sich die
Finanzmärkte während der Nullzeit ansehen  dass sie
vor
allem in den USA stark unreguliert waren
und auf einer effizienten Markthypothese basierten
, nämlich
dass, wenn man einen Markt nicht reguliert,
am Ende
die guten Produkte leben werden, weil der Markt effizient ist, die guten Finanzprodukte
und die schlechten  Diejenigen werden irgendwie
aussortiert, die natürlich sind. Qualität wird
kontrolliert
wie etwas Natürliche Qualität,
die von einem effizienten Markt kontrolliert wird.
Was wir in diesen Jahren herausgefunden haben,
war, dass es viele schlechte Papiere gab,
die tatsächlich eine ganze Weile leben konnten
, das ist der Grund, warum Sie  bekam eine Subprime-
Krise in den USA,
so dass eigentlich mehr oder weniger schlechte
Finanzpapiere lange überleben
und
sie möglicherweise künstlich aufblasen könnten, so
dass sogar Alan Greenspan zurückkehren musste, schau,
die Hypothese des effizienten Marktes ist
wahrscheinlich nicht richtig, weil schlecht
Papiere könnten lange leben,
das gleiche gilt für einen unregulierten
Informationsmarkt,
es stellt sich heraus, dass, wenn Sie ihn nicht
irgendwie regulieren  und wenn man die leute nicht erzieht
, damit richtig umzugehen,
dann gibt es keine garantie dafür, dass der
informationsmarkt in
gleicher weise so effizient ist, dass die wahrheitsgemäßen
informationen am ende überleben
und die schlechten informationen nicht und
dann kommt das  Bei einem stellt sich
dann die Frage, was dagegen zu
tun ist. Regulierung ist teilweise das eine,
Bildung ist das andere, und dann gibt es
in den USA neue Studien, die
zeigen, dass wir
tatsächlich eine Art wissenschaftliche Neugier wecken sollten
, wenn wir also eine Information erhalten
machen wir uns keine Gedanken darüber, ob wir
zustimmen oder nicht,
aber machen wir uns Gedanken darüber, woher es kommt,
wer die Quellen
sind, ob es mögliche
Absichten gibt, und so weiter und so
weiter,
und das Tolle an Neugier ist, dass
Neugier normalerweise keine ist  - voreingenommen
Ich bin nur neugierig und wenn wir also
eher eine Informationsneugier wecken können als das
Auswählen von Informationen und so weiter, dann ist das
Teil dieses Bildungsporos  tfolio von
uns menschen
im informationszeitalter ist
nein und ich denke das stimmt absolut ich
denke es ist fair zu sagen, dass
jeder, der online ein profil hat,
irgendwie ein reporter
ist, damit verdient facebook auch
sein geld  Sie berichten
von Ihrem äh über Ihre Freunde,
was Sie erleben usw. usw.,
aber Sie sind kein regulierter Händler,
obwohl Sie sich natürlich,
wenn Sie sich bei Facebook oder Instagram
oder was
auch immer anmelden, auch den
Gemeinschaftsstandards anschließen, die sie haben  was
bedeutet, dass du andere Leute nicht schikanieren
darfst, du darfst nicht absichtlich
falsche Dinge sagen usw. Nun, ich denke,
eigentlich kannst du das tun. Ich glaube nicht, dass
es eine Regel dagegen gibt, aber es
gibt bestimmte
Community-Standards, an die du dich halten solltest,
wenn  Sie möchten ihre Plattform nutzen,
aber die Leute nehmen sie einfach ab und
gehen dann auf ihre Website und sie denken nicht
darüber nach,
aber in gewissem Sinne
versuchen sie hier zu sagen, dass sie es sind  Prinzipiell
versuchen wir,
unsere Produkte, unsere Journalisten zu regulieren,
und jetzt kann sich jeder online Journalist nennen,
aber es ist ein sehr unfairer
Informationsmarkt, denn wenn jeder
Journalist ist, dann sind einige
Journalisten stärker reguliert als
andere, während er auf srf sagen kann, was er
will,
nein  Sie werden also durch Maßnahmen reguliert
, was guter Journalismus ist, und
wahrscheinlich sogar durch
eine Verantwortung gegenüber den Medien,
was sie veröffentlichen können,
damit Sie gegen
Desperados kämpfen, die keine solchen Vorschriften haben
und wenn sie keine Spekulationen haben, in die sie sich einbringen können
Umlaufinformationen, die
wahrscheinlich weiter geschrieben werden,
gesehen und gehört werden als Philosophie,
stehen bei
allem Respekt still, haben aber nicht die
gleiche
Wirkung wie ein Experiment.
Ein normatives Konzept
, das ist eine sehr gute Frage, für die wir
derzeit sozusagen das Zentrum sind  Der
Informationsstil ist zwei Jahre alt, also haben
wir noch nicht alle Antworten bisher haben
wir uns mit dem beschäftigt  Schrauben und
Muttern verschiedener Blasenphänomene,
aber Sie könnten sich vorstellen, dass es
bestimmte
gutartige Blasen gibt, oder Sie könnten über eine gutartige Aufmerksamkeitsverteilung sprechen,
also sagen die UN die 20 Ziele der UN richtig oder die
großen Herausforderungen des
Weltwirtschaftsforums,
dass die Welt dort möglicherweise nicht falsch ist  In einer
Art
überstimulierender Aufmerksamkeit für
Klimamigration, Gesundheit usw., damit dieser Ort
ein besserer Ort für uns Menschen ist, den wir
teilen können. Aus dieser Perspektive, wenn wir
eine
Art Einheit haben, wenn Sie einheitliche Ziele haben,
dann könnte es manchmal sein
gute idee
, diesen zielen mehr aufmerksamkeit zu widmen
und dann die menschen dazu zu bringen, das
richtige
für sich und den rest der
welt zu tun
philosophie
, das ist eine tiefgründige frage, physikalisch gesehen
ja, schau mal,
steven weinberg war ein nobelpreisträger
in der
physik, hat es einmal sehr schön gesagt  Es ist
, als wären wir alle Realisten, wir schnüffeln alle irgendwie nach der Wahrheit, dass es kein r gibt, wenn du nicht nach diesem
festen Punkt schnüffelst  Wirklich daran zu riechen
bedeutet nicht, dass die Wahrheit ein
leichtes Spiel ist, uh und manchmal
sagt es dir nicht
genau, was wir haben. Manchmal stellst du
der Welt nur die falschen Fragen
und
sie widersetzt sich  Wenn wir Antworten geben, sind wir manchmal
auf andere Weise voreingenommen usw.,
aber ich denke, es ist fair zu sagen, und ich
habe vorher darauf angespielt,
dass sogar die Wissenschaft in einem Punkt
die Wahrheit findet, und dann müssen wir natürlich
auch erkennen, dass wir es auch sind
von Geldgebern bis hin zu
politischem Klima
genau reguliert werden, und es gibt auch all das
, aber
bisher sind wir immer noch eine Spezies auf diesem
Planeten wie viele andere Spezies, von denen
ich
annehme, dass das Selbst, von dem Sie wissen
, dass es diese Spezies intakt hält  für
die zukünftigen Generationen
ist etwas, das wir immer noch gerne tun werden,
und
wenn wir diesen Weg fortsetzen,
fordern wir uns vielleicht ein wenig zu sehr heraus,
also warum nutzen wir nicht einfach, während wir es hinzufügen,
die Mittel und Methoden der Wissenschaft
zu machen  sicher t  ass die nächste
Generation eine Welt zum Leben hat
und das noch eine Weile andauert und das
erfordert, dass wir
die Tatsache akzeptieren, dass es
etwas gibt, das wahr und etwas
falsch genannt wird, und mittendrin dann
natürlich unsere Visionen und
Ideologien kommen müssen
In dieser komplizierten Gleichung, bei der
es darum geht, ein Mensch zu sein und noch dazu verantwortungsbewusst
für sich selbst und für sein Familienfeld
[Musik] zu sein, sind
gut aussehende Social Bots im Grunde
eine algorithmische Möglichkeit, die Sie
erzwingen könnten, dass Sie sich auf
die Möglichkeit berufen können, diese zu bauen
Computerprogramme, die jetzt entsprechend tun,
was sie
tun sollen,
sind im Grunde genommen die öffentliche Meinung zu beeinflussen,
und das liegt natürlich daran, und
aus philosophischer Sicht ist das
irgendwie interessant, denn wenn man sich die
Erkenntnistheorie
bei großen Erkenntnistheoretikern ansieht  sehr
in den vergangenen
Jahrhunderten sehr besorgt um das
Individuum und was das Individuum
wissen oder glauben kann usw  Was wir jetzt normalerweise
bekommen, ist im Grunde in vielerlei
Hinsicht von Seelenpsychologen,
dass wir, wenn wir selbst keine weiteren Informationen finden können,
was wir gut machen, dazu neigen, uns
anzuschauen, was unsere unmittelbare epistemische
Umgebung über so und so und so und so und so und
so
und so glaubt  Wir gehen davon aus, dass das als sozialer
Beweis bezeichnet wird, da könnte etwas sehr
Vernünftiges daran sein, weil man manchmal
die Erfahrungen anderer Leute
anzapft und durch
die Weisheit der Menge klüger wird, aber aber
richtig, wenn man Bots daran beteiligt,
dann gibt es noch eine ganz andere  eine ganz andere
Situation, weil
sie im Grunde nur Programme
sind, die einen Fingerabdruck ausgeben, bei dem Sie
nicht unterscheiden können
, sprechen wir über einen menschlichen Fingerabdruck
, sprechen wir über einen Bot-Fingerabdruck,
und viele Bots können dennoch eine Menge
sozialer
Beweise erstellen  dass kein Agent
dahintersteckt
und aus dieser Perspektive kann man
sich auf viele verschiedene Arten beeinflussen lassen,
natürlich kann man es auch positiv nutzen,
also angenommen, man benutzt  Bots
auch, um
Fragen anzuregen, die wir für wichtig halten, die
aber eine politische oder ideologische
globale Diskussion über Herausforderungen erfordern und
welche man irgendwie gemeinsam
angehen muss und welche
nicht, aber es wird keinen
Weg geben, wie
man das regulieren kann  oder Bots aus dem
Internet
zu verbannen wird nicht passieren,
aber was ist mit den Parteisoldaten
, die nicht Teil der Partei sind, aber
glauben, dass das, was sie sagen, richtig ist
oder was auch immer,
es ist nur zu sagen, dass jede Partei es kann
Sagen Sie es
und sie können es wahrscheinlich bei
ihren Kernwählern durchsetzen,
aber es könnte eine Menge anderer
Interessen daran beteiligt sein, die über
die politische Ideologie usw
Das Thema, mit dem wir diese Show gestartet haben,
ist, ob wir sagen können, ob die Signale,
die scheinbar öffentlichen Signale, die wir
aus dem Internet erhalten, echt und irgendwie
repräsentativ
für welchen Menschen auch immer sind  Viele glauben oder reden
nicht unbedingt, was sie glauben, sondern
ihre sofortige Reaktion
oder Bot-Generierung oder andere Dinge, und
das ist eine der großen Herausforderungen des
Lebens im Informationszeitalter, dass es
für uns schwierig ist
, die tatsächliche Meinung
von ihnen zu unterscheiden  diejenigen, die online operieren, ist
erstens, ob sie ehrlich sind,
was sie denken,
und andererseits, ob sie wirklich
da sind,
oder sprechen wir über Verhalten usw., und
wieder wissen wir nicht genau, wie das
funktioniert, aber wir wissen
es  Es gab eine Menge Bot-
Aufmerksamkeit in Bezug
auf politische Kandidaten oder Programme
usw.
und dass sie eine Rolle spielen.
Die Frage ist, ob wir wissen, dass es einen
Weg gibt, unseren Ausweg zu regulieren,
und ich dachte, ich finde Chancen, schlank zu sein,
okay,
ähm,
okay  Also eine ist, höre ich also,
wann immer ich
ein Like oder eine positive Bewertung oder einen Kommentar zu
etwas absetze,
habe ich meinen eigenen unabhängigen Grund zu
glauben,
dass alles, was ich sage, richtig ist, kann
ich präsentieren  meine eigene Argumentation
oder probiere ich nur die von jemand anderem
, die ich nicht überprüft habe,
mit anderen Worten, funktioniert eine Argumentation
tatsächlich für mich
und glaube ich auch, dass die Argumentation
, die für mich funktioniert, für jemand anderen funktionieren sollte,
nämlich gibt es eine Verbreitung von Argumenten?  Das ist
meine aufrichtige Meinung
, das ist etwas, was der Einzelne
manchmal tatsächlich überprüfen kann.
Teil eins, Teil zwei, was sehr,
sehr wichtig ist
von dem, was andere Leute da
draußen glauben, oder wird das getrübt,
und wenn das systemisch
getrübt wird, sollte ich vielleicht nicht
meine Meinung in dieses Recht einbringen, und dann,
Nummer drei, ist
es nicht wichtig, dass Sie glauben,
was wichtig ist, was Sie sind
Voraussetzungen, um a zu glauben,
nämlich es ist nicht interessant, dass Sie a
glauben, und ich glaube nicht,
was interessant ist, was sind Ihre Kunst,
was sind Ihre Voraussetzungen, um nicht zu glauben,
und ich,
und das  Der Grund dafür ist, dass
wir durch den Vergleich von Prämissen
tatsächlich über die
Unterschiede aufgeklärt werden.
Es ist nicht interessant,
zuzustimmen, nicht zuzustimmen, was interessant ist, zu verstehen, warum wir zustimmen oder nicht zustimmen,
denn darin liegt Erleuchtung und an
sich sicher für eine Weile den Stecker gezogen
und
wir werden ausgesteckt und der Grund ist, dass wir
nur
so viel Aufmerksamkeit zuweisen können. Schau, nimm
ein Abendessen mit deinen Freunden an,
wenn einer von ihnen sich hinsetzt, sie
auf ihr Telefon schauen, wird es im Grunde
die ganze Sache vergiften und so was ich '  Ich
versuche hier zu sagen, dass es für zwischenmenschliche Beziehungen
tatsächlich förderlich sein könnte,
nur
herumzusitzen und zu reden
angenehm,
aber natürlich ist diese Blase
diese besondere Blase, die
neun Monate andauern wird,
und dann wirst du die Welt sehen, und
die Welt wird geben  Ihre
Eindrücke, die sich sehr, sehr davon
unterscheiden, stellen Sie
jetzt sicher, dass das, was auch immer in der
Blase ist, anpassungsfähig genug ist,
um tatsächlich in der Lage zu sein, mit dieser
Art von
Eindrücken umzugehen, die es bekommen wird, und
bis jetzt haben wir uns gut geschlagen,
aber erkennen, dass wir es waren  Menschen seit
000 Jahren, das war's, die Welt ist
Milliarden von Jahren alt,
also sind wir aus dieser Perspektive hier nur ein
Komma,
und was wir die Periode der Erleuchtung nennen
, ist nicht einmal ein Komma,
Sie fangen gerade an, ein bisschen wie ein Komma zu zeichnen
Teil eines Alphabets oder Teil eines
Buchstabens, und um nur das zu sagen,
dass wir für eine sehr, sehr
kurze Zeit
für eine sehr, sehr kurze Zeit da sind, und wenn Sie
darauf bestehen wollen, dass wir
für eine längere Zeit da sein werden
Dann müssen wir sicherstellen, dass die
Informationen, die wir zwischen uns übermitteln,
mehr oder weniger wahrheitsgemäß sind, oder uns zumindest
anpassen oder versuchen, es zu sein,
weil wir sonst entgleisen, und
warum dumm sein, wenn Sie nicht
beide genannt werden müssen,
danke
Plaza
[Musik]
Sie